-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well
tonight,
and now we're gonna
get to the news.
President Biden tonight
delivered his first
State of the Union address,
and thank God he got that
Supreme Court Justice in,
'cause there was not much else
to talk about.
Uh, I think there's a new
"Batman" movie this week.
[ Laughter ]
"The New York Times"
published a report yesterday
that US officials
are currently debating
Russian President Vladimir
Putin's grip on reality.
In related news, Putin just
ordered troops into Hogwarts.
[ Laughter ]
When asked by a reporter
at a Black History Month event
yesterday if Americans should be
worried about nuclear war,
President Biden said no.
Yeah, come on.
Putin isn't gonna bomb
the only people
still supporting him.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, President Biden
was asked if Americans
should be worried about
nuclear war, and he said no.
But then the CDC said yes,
and the FDA said,
"We'll let you know
in four to six weeks,"
so I don't know
what's gonna happen.
Officials in Ukraine last week
asked Apple CEO Tim Cook
to ban Russia from using
the company's products
and services in response
to their attack on Ukraine.
Well, if being the only country
whose messages in the group chat
are green doesn't
force Russia to surrender,
I don't know what will.
[ Russian accent ]
This is embarrassment.
We are only green.
No one even read these texts.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
The Senate last night failed
to pass the Women's Health
Protection Act,
and West Virginia Senator Joe
Manchin voted with Republicans.
Okay, how many times does
someone have to vote
with Republicans before
you consider him a Republican?
It's kind of like saying
Keith Richards played
with the Rolling Stones again.
Yeah,
'cause he's a Rolling Stone.
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi told
reporters yesterday
that Congress will support
"whatever it is"
the Ukraine needs amid Russia's
invasion of the country.
Well, unless
it's universal healthcare...
in which case there's all --
there's a co-pay, it's a mess.
New Orleans held its first
full-scale
Mardi Gras celebration today
since 2020 when
the coronavirus pandemic hit
but required masks
in indoor public spaces.
Still, men were throwing beads
and yelling,
"Show us your chin!"
[ Laughter ]
Today was National Pig Day.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"When isn't it" asked an --
What is wrong with you?
[ Laughter ]
Why are you cheering for it
like you even knew
it was a thing?
I don't understand
that reaction.
[ Laughter ]
[ Chuckles ]
If you cared so much,
why didn't you know?
[ Light laughter ]
I'm gonna tell the joke now,
alright?
[ Chuckles ]
I told you there should be
a National Pig Day!
[ Laughter ]
Today was National Pig Day.
"When isn't it?"
asked an exhausted Charlotte.
[ Laughter ]
"This friendship is starting
to feel very one-sided."
It lost its momentum
a little bit
when everybody
lost their [bleep] minds
about National Pig Day.
[ Laughter ]
You know what else?
I bet someone here
had bacon this morning.
[ Laughter ]
On National Pig Day.
[ Chuckles ] You monsters.
In honor of St. Patrick's Day,
Dunkin' Donuts
is offering
a shamrock macchiato.
In a related story, Italy
has declared war on Ireland.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Dunkin' Donuts is offering
a shamrock macchiato,
which is green
and features Irish cream flavor.
So, look for that
on a sidewalk near you.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody!